[Music]
subject for today
[Music]
it's called an attempt at on beat
sipping and then on the beat
yeah this is not good he's choking my
lord he's choking already i am joking
you are a little bit late to the show i
am excited
to uh broadcast the downfall of western
civilization with you today
um it's the continuation of fraud week
hey
some people have been saying stop with
the fraud week listen when there's no
longer a fraudulent election
your request will be granted so many
states today we'll be covering uh we'll
be covering nevada yeah pennsylvania and
then ending on michigan because
both uh myself and of course in third
chair today from compound media dave
landau
are we're both michiganders yes we are
hello everyone and you're the whitest
man in detroit that's correct
the last one i hear yes and the last one
well there's two
the last one without ever can only be
one beanie
and a coffee shop detroit is nothing but
criminals
with tear tattoos and hipsters and the
hipsters i mean they're
it's very short-lived it's a short they
recycle them very quickly
like i'm going to go in and make a
difference and then there's an epidemic
of hipster rape
surprise just said who saw that one
coming
skyler uh quarterback garrett is here
he's accepted amongst no communities
audio wade has a puffy face he won't be
tomorrow because he has facial surgery
that's true
yeah i'm going to change my face and
then tokyo black turning it black
that would only work i only do that off
camera
uh and then gerald is here how are you i
am well sir i don't care
uh but uh i i do i care about you very
much just not
i lied i don't like lying to my audience
right off the bat
we'll also make you're a good guy we do
have some good news
two vaccines now not just one two
vaccines now are available they're
competing
two and uh we were told that there would
be no vaccines here's the thing
and this is a question i have several
questions today does anybody out there
genuinely believe when we talk about
donald trump's mishandling of the
pandemic anyone genuinely believe that
joe biden would have gotten these
vaccines to market
faster or as fast do you know what do
you know what got us two vaccines
before the end of november which donald
trump said would happen and they said
was impo logistically impossible
cutting red tape and deregulation
basically a disney villains policies
[Laughter]
that's really what it is like oh you
know this town did really well until the
guy came in and deregulated it now those
uh
the big oil company comes in and then
it's just you know matthew mcconaughey
or
sam elliott like well i want to rape you
of your resources you're like oh
we get it and he doesn't spend any time
with his kids so we'll be talking about
vaccine warp speed what it is versus
what joe biden wanted to do
but first uh you know how yesterday we
talked about we are covering nevada and
michigan
right sorry nevada and pennsylvania
tomorrow is michigan but we had to cover
this because yesterday we covered
georgia
and a lot of people skim over this
because it's such a similar story
uh where yesterday we talked about how
there was a memory card yeah they found
about 2600 new votes the overwhelming
majority of which were
for donald trump yeah yeah they found a
second memory card
after we had broadcast with another 2700
votes in fayette county georgia
uh again the majority of which for for
donald trump they're treating they're
treating
voting cards like their expansion packs
on the on an n64
if i want to play donkey kong 64 i need
more voting cards
if you hit 3 000 you got gotta log out
yeah
you have to blow on the votes you have
to you have a notebook with your
passwords before they have the only way
the proper memory functions think about
this for a second there's no evidence
of voter fraud sure we didn't use the
term just voter fraud we talked about
irregularity right right that's also
important
56 what are we 5400 but somewhere
between 50 depending which report you
use 50 200 and 6 000 votes that they
just
found in one state
it's not of concern to you and by the
way this is not even with a real recount
not even with a canvassing it's just
people counting the same way they
counted before
i don't know yeah what is it hey what
does this card do yeah
son of a [ __ ] there's another phone
look at that like somebody checked their
jacket pocket like oh crap
can you imagine if you checked your
jacket pocket you found fifty four
hundred dollars
yeah you'd probably tell someone as
opposed to nothing
but a secret i know i'd board up my
windows with bristol boards i wouldn't
let anyone know
and reject poll workers i know if i
found one laptop with a bunch of stuff
on it that no one wants to see i would
definitely hide that
i didn't give it to rudy giuliani yeah
geek squad
here's the thing about the laptop the
laptop is uh there's some things that
are funny but there are things
not so funny what do you mean so many
clocks stephen
there was there's so many eminem he was
on our show and he was saying like
there's something that i don't want to
talk about
well now we know unspeakable sydney
powell said we need to investigate it
more and anthony weiner's laptop we
forgot about that little bastard well
he's still around really
what's up anthony weiner apparently
there might be some criminal activity
from that laptop and it might link to uh
i don't know how it links to under binds
they're all horrible people let's just
be clear the people who represent i
prefer the term collectors
yes collectors like uh matthew
i love how jesus put tax collectors on
par with criminals and prostitutes
here's another thing we're hitting
michigan tomorrow but uh a board of
canvassers in michigan this happened
last night refused to certify they were
deadlocked two to two
to certify the vote for joe biden in
wayne county uh and then they reversed
it so this is considered a big win they
reversed it people say
why did they reverse it so this happened
last night um
i'll tell you what i i have a we don't
know exactly why they reversed it so
quickly and it almost seemed fearfully
but i have a guess monica palmer and
william hartman
will forever be known in southeastern
michigan as
two racists who did something so
unprecedented that they disenfranchised
hundreds of thousands of black voters
from detroit because they were ordered
probably i know monica you think
q told you to do it or some other crazy
stuff like that
but just know when you try to sleep
tonight that millions of people around
the world now on twitter know the name
monica palmer
and william hartman as two people come
questions
it gets worse racist and without an
understanding
of what integrity means or a shred of
human decency
and what that tells us is you miss
monica palmer from gross point woods
which has a history of racism wow
are deciding to enable and continue to
perpetuate
the racist history of this country now i
am not trying to encourage
violence against the nazi who lives on
184 oak lawn apartment number two
in gross point woods wow keep in mind
the hunter biden story was removed from
twitter because of doxing
that's what they claimed because it
showed some private emails
they gave the name municipality and i'm
pretty sure on twitter
the address wow why it's like
how do they reverse the decision i don't
know if they're about to send some black
bloc protesters with molotov cocktails
to your condominium complex guess what
i might change your mind too yeah it's
not worth it i'm a volunteer
and by the way their job is to do this
their job if there's irregularities that
they have to sort through first you
don't certify the vote yet well
here's another thing they may have had
reason for for pause because and we're
still confirming this so you can fact
check at twitter but it seems that this
comes from legitimate source
uh there's new proof that the same
ballots in detroit
were run one two three four times
four times the same ballot in wayne
county
pause the detroit tigers mascot
i just want to make sure i'm following
along four erosions of our
constitutional republic
soon we'll all be living in trash can
i'm from gross point
and uh you know i feel that just because
we put a giant wall between our city and
detroit does not make us racist no
[Laughter]
plus they're still you guys aren't any
better off because they've in detroit
they've run out of people to kill
exactly they have we have to go over
that give them something to do
you have people walking into your
neighborhood and driving out yes
all the time i'm not kidding twice in my
front yard i can't figure it out funk
master flex doesn't even live there so
somehow i don't know they must be
there's just
people are going to gross but it's a
good place to purchase cars legally
people don't realize this detroit
invented the carjacking
when my father when my father taught me
to drive yeah because he learned to
drive in detroit he had to teach me how
to avoid carjacking he said here's what
happens
you always leave some space between you
at least a full car's length between you
and the bumper in front of you when
you're stopped at a light and you have
the wheels slightly angled just like you
don't want to have the wheels angled if
you're turning
left at a red light you're saying always
have them slightly angled that way if
someone because what they would do is
they would ram you
pin you and then carjack you that way if
someone ran you you say bye [ __ ] and
you go off ah yeah it's right after you
learned a parallel park actually
yeah it's on the tower yeah they tell
you and then watch out for the deer
roaming downtown yeah it's
on the test right next to the box that
you check uh caucasian as well as
not hispanic or latino right yeah how
many feet away should you be from your
carjacker how far should you reach out
for a dime
again i don't know what it takes i don't
know what it okay we now have over 5000
votes that they just found and we just
gave you some
pretty strong evidence that they've
counted ballots one two three four times
which by the way coincides it
corroborates the affidavits
which are sworn testimony effectively
under oath of people saying i just saw
them put in the ballot in a bunch of
times
people writing down the affidavits
thought like oh you must be misspeaking
no one would be that blatant with their
criminal activity no no i saw them just
put it in and run the ballot a bunch of
times it was a cartoon with his tongue
falling out because a pretty bunny lady
came by
no evidence whatsoever uh
anyway we're going to be continuing with
voter fraud in the vaccine but uh please
hey
we are now on parlor people who don't
know parlor um
we're still on facebook twitter and all
but parlor is a pretty good app right
now it's a place where free speech
actually still exists
we will always fight on the territories
where we can youtube twitter facebook
until it gets to a point if they just
completely throttle your voice i'm not
saying that's happened with any of the
platforms yet but
it's getting pretty close so parlor
thank you uh we're at stephen crowder on
parliament of course
to consider joining mug club louder with
crowder.com mug club we still have the
crowder election stream promo code
that's 30
off because the election is not called
despite what stelter tells you
because he doesn't want to pay nuisance
money and
um there's no free content without you
uh subscribing on mug club so we really
do appreciate it people like how do you
do this without uh
selling uh little vibrating toothbrushes
and bed sheets and gold
and tom selleck hasn't taken my house
that's because
you guys join up we're not funded by a
foreign caliphate it's you
and mugs and uh we'll have another 30
minutes uh exclusive on on mug club
um uh hold on what are they saying at
cena oh they're talking about the
vaccine by the way the new virtue signal
is the [ __ ] haircut
oh is it that's sanjay gupta because he
wants you to know i can't go get my hair
cut because i'm social distancing
and uh so that's how he looks wow it
just looks greasy
yes what was the excuse before coping
it's like it's like he's uh he's on
break on the set of the outsiders
only lost his comb and switchblade
we all had one as a kid
and then they stab you yeah yeah take
your call you can still sharpen a comb
myself four times
hey by the way this is awesome we don't
want to be insensitive it's it's trans
awareness week
right and this is of course everyone
twitter we would not have just like with
black history month
we would not have tried to hijack it and
we wouldn't have done fraud week
had we known that that being said you
know we will make sure that
in the future if there is no fraudulent
election that's stolen we'll
move fraud week over to make room of
course for a beautiful brave trans
awareness week
this is about visibility for trans
people and so we are going to
simultaneously celebrate
trans awareness week with fraud week uh
trans
awareness uh thank you for everything
that you do
[Music]
well we see you i am harder than
astrophysics
i hope everyone in this studio enjoys my
droplets that's true
don't worry it's not aerosol aerosol is
a finer mist by the way your single ply
cotton mask at home unless washed in an
industrial hospital washing machine
does nothing according to science
someone sent me that paper
fauchi i'm eyeing you and i know you
love the limelight we have an open seat
and a booster seat right here for you
i hope that moisture doesn't loosen my
duct tape
what i have no idea duct taped oh
the awareness of taping it back
i still don't get it
i'll give it to
this you a turn all right but we are
going to continue we're going to be
talking about the vaccines and we are
going to be talking about
uh operation warp speed but of course we
are trying to provide you with a service
right now going state by state
of the no evidence so it's time to
continue fraud week
[Music]
you know what spit takes aren't worth it
yeah you just got it everywhere
i don't think it hit the camera but it
might have did it actually hit the
camera i don't know i'm trying to say
is there anything are there droplets on
your screen that was a good spit tape
that's what it was yeah the parts when
you're a kid and you first see a spit
take and then you're looking for any
excuse to do the best exactly you're
just like hey give me some water
was it funny
[Laughter]
you're going down to the gross point
mall what was it what's the mall down
there uh
eastland eastland it's nice there's a
purple suit store left
yes but all just all purple
there's a purple store and it's right
next to the polymer playground where
kids like playing a giant piece of
french toast but they're actually just
[ __ ] selling heroin
for one on fridays
which by the way everyone's saying hey
there's an empty holster here i don't
know what happened to my gun i think i
think uh
i think i gave it to a kid so we're
continuing fraud week
he didn't he did not uh this week nevada
and pennsylvania we're cataloging this
on crowderbit so that you can have this
as a reference point
uh and i want to get through the facts
first so that i don't get anything wrong
and then
of course we'll go to some competition
let's go to nevada first this uh week
the clark county commission right they
threw out a local election you can bring
this up their token on
uh because there were quote too many
discrepancies to be sure of the election
results
and there were 153 000 votes in this
municipality so they had to toss it
that's a local election and i don't know
if there's anyone we don't think it's
gonna affect the national election but
that's still kind of like if you have to
toss an election
you have to toss 153 000 votes because
you can't even
get close to matching up the totals
maybe there are a few memory cards under
someone's mattress next to their gold
and reverse mortgage contract i have no
idea
but go looking for them you'll find them
where's the memory card maybe it's
wearing stripes in a candy cane forest
like waldo why does waldo always hide in
places
with stripes waldo we could find you
easily
anywhere else well i don't know i'm at
the candy i'm at the candy cane
amusement park well there's your problem
waldo
well maybe he doesn't want to be found
maybe he doesn't want to be
found bill devane found 5 000 votes
so this was 153 000 votes in a local
election that were tossed and by the way
this does transl these direct votes
are a local election not national but
this does translate to the shenanigans
that you see at the national level matt
schlapp
summarized the problems going into the
nevada elections
highlighting that there were all kinds
of irregularities even at a national
level in clark county here he is because
you won't believe me
in all my years in politics
i have never seen the types of voter
irregularity
we have seen in clark county
the zeal to push reckless unsolicited
mail-in voting resulted in 50 percent
of ballots coming through the mail and a
10-fold increase
in mail ballots in clark county
fact the voter list was
appropriately scrubbed including the
press reports
after foia requests of not
scrubbing over 80 000 primary voters
before the general election ballots
were made no evidence
illegal ballots never should have been
mailed
and they never should have ended up in
the final tally
in tomato tomato how did this happen
this happened with a reckless change
in nevada election rules right before
the general election
which reduced the democratic norms
of meaningful observation by the media
and by americans says you the reduction
of ballot security
and almost the elimination of signature
verification
yeah i know you feel for their audio
guys
he actually ended the speech by saying
you just got match slapped you just got
slapped
you just got schlepped and by the way
you usually don't see someone that tan
with hair that white that thickness like
a walking photo negative
um so here's some other facts for
dominion voting the systems that we've
talked about they were used in 16 out of
17 jurisdictions in nevada with of
course a history of glitches we don't
have them in this election because no
one's
really looking for them but in previous
elections uh a whistleblower by the way
with the clark county election
uh clark county elections department
claimed that poll workers
fabricated proof of residence right for
data for uh illegal voters this is under
a sworn affidavit again we're just doing
nevada right now we're gonna get to
pennsylvania we'll
we're cooking with gas cooking with the
slow downfall and erosion of our
democracy
yeah it's renewable apparently
every every four years and midterms high
smoke points and recounts
yeah it's like palm oil somewhere
somewhere there's a paleo or a keto
person like i get that
i get that i need to get my saturated
fats in because i believe it's a better
energy source you
[ __ ] so uh another witness saw a
biden-harris van
unloading ballots that were filled out
and then they were sealed in envelopes
uh and here's the people formed a human
shield
to prevent poll watchers from observing
so we'll continue with this because
there's some
and be aware of the fact checkers we're
going to get into some of the fact
checks that you see that aren't really
they fact check themselves
but when they say well it was a mistake
they formed a human
shield to block poll workers we used to
form a human shield so you know black
people could saunter on up to the bar
and eat a piece of pie at the diner
maybe not be bothered by german
shepherds while they enjoy a brunch now
we're forming
shields to prevent the preservation of
our constitutional republic
which is better than making a shield out
of your parents trash can so you can go
be antifa and burn down your city
that's true that is true and if they
don't even use metal trash cans
no it's plastic is this a recycling bin
this is this isn't gonna this won't even
stop my switchblade comb
it says it says keep philly clean on the
side
it's part of the message well we don't
all have time for professional shields
we can't all have plate carriers
well listen when the revolution comes
i'm just saying plate carrier is not a
bad idea thanks mark
then in nevada the republican party of
course they found over 3000 specific
instances of ballots that appear to be
cast improperly
up to 10 000 ballots are alleged that
have allegedly been cast by people who
don't appear to live in the state at all
or dead people and these have been
referred by the way
to attorney general bill barr who um is
on my list of it's not gay
hmm no yeah this is
what's it what you mean
that's what i mean i guess it's just me
listen you know what yeah i went out on
a limb
expecting support no you got none yeah
well well you left us that we didn't
know where you were
i didn't know if you meant gay bar
[Laughter]
manners to ours oh well i just i don't
know if he would be there i'd have to
lure him
if you're going to bring in illegal
ballots can you not use the biden harris
van to do it right like an unmarked
try a little harder yeah that's like
it's like a pedophile so
know the whole point is have a panel van
so we can't see in but you wrote rapist
honestly yeah
he's like a trump van or something i
don't know yeah you have that
glass box porn truck but it's a one-way
mirror
[Laughter]
look at this stephen that's what that
would be in a stevenson golf room where
he's a spy but he rides up in a van he's
like
ah my van says secret spy
[Laughter]
why would you do that steven seagal it
has a v12 no it doesn't
by the way here's a memory card four
thousand more votes
we're supposed to campaign and commit
fraud i don't
know what are we about to say there i
was going to say i mean none of these
stories
are are far-fetched right so it would be
very easy for the news to go yeah
that seems like it has some credibility
to it we should probably cover that we
should probably talk about this
and yet they just lump it into no
evidence no facts these aren't stories
these are sworn affidavits
and then there's confirmation so for
example we had a sworn affidavit with
someone saying hey they put in five
ballots in michigan
27 times right ah we're gonna dismiss
that suit now we have evidence that
there have been at least several ballots
counted three
four times and the truth is with the
recounts that they're doing in georgia
there's no real way to know how many
times that's happened i don't know if
they do it by just adding up the total
from dominion voting the the digital
total and the hand count total and say
there's a discrepancy
how do they only spot one i know there
has to be an
a true like you said a true audit of
votes we have to know what's going on
because there's too many of these
like you said not just stories sworn
affidavits people coming out in
positions of power and saying hey this
this doesn't happen like
this does not happen we have to take a
second and make sure that this is
accurate and
nothing cnn nothing i think we just have
to discount anyone who says definitively
this cannot recount there is no election
fraud you might find one or four votes
well in one county six thousand well so
you know what
it's a give or take it's like the polls
there's a plus or minus 12.
it's like yeah it's like a parent saying
to the kid like what's behind your back
nothing
yeah for me okay
to see here sounds like it's just a comb
yeah
it's not like it's a kajillion vote i
mean
yeah fine it's not like it's not like
it's enough to sway an election the most
important country the world has ever
seen
what again what does it take at this
point for
now we're not saying that this is
evidence that there's enough fraud that
would have changed the vote total but
there is certainly enough evidence here
not only sworn affidavits but hard
evidence and numbers and vote tallies
and ballots
that warrant an investigation at this
point and you of course you're saying
well we're not going to investigate well
hold on a second
if no one took it upon themselves to
investigate at all
those 5 500 votes would never have been
found never counted you say that all
votes matter all votes count and they're
talking about on cnn how lindsey graham
wants to toss out legal votes or he
called put pressure to toss out legal
votes because someone spoke with a
person who spoke with a person who knows
somebody who saw this guy
who knows that lindsey graham passed out
at 31 flavors last night
[Music]
but what about the illegals what about
the illegal votes we want to talk to
illegal votes what about these legal
votes to the tune of
thousands that have just been found do
those not matter yeah do those not
matter at all because cnn is too busy
right now poppy harlow and uh
jim bruschetta they're talking about uh
mask mandates in south dakota let's go
to duckface lady see what she has to
say good morning poppy jim we're
actually in front of the city
council city she has skrillex
good facilities where morning not
possible
i've been up all night doing ecstasy
pure mdma that's a very big deal two
falls is south dakota's largest city
and as coronavirus cases and deaths
continue to rise
the governor continuing to oppose any
sort of mask rule
good for her to be good she should
christine
of southwest don't show her that's only
going to hurt your kid people who
support her just for those games
she can come out and say kovate is a
complete and total hoax
good enough for me and those uh michigan
doctors send me her address
look at those presumes
wow maybe at least your office number
what is it sweet see
they were showing it earlier too and i
was just watching where they're like
it's it's
there's an outbreak here in south dakota
here's an empty hospital parking lot
yeah it's like oh counter for more
yeah yeah it looks like marish
look coronavirus confirmed cases and she
just tosses in deaths well hold on a
second again we're talking about one
city so that's the only time i mentioned
deaths when they're talking about a
small municipality
because four people die and that
increases the overall death count
what about nationally it's actually
remarkable because if you look at the
total number of cases and you look at
the deaths
it seems that the disease is becoming
less lethal i'm not saying that aren't
deaths and i'm not saying that there
won't be an increase in total deaths but
in relation to total cases
again catching covered twice 54 million
cases you know how many people caught it
twice we talked about it yesterday pop
quiz anyone paying attention
four you got it i'll give it i'm going
three i was expecting a joke but just
accurate response no
i prefer uh every now and then to look
like i have a brain but i don't
uh i'm discounting the first guy because
he was it was debatable whether he
actually had it the first time or not
remember
that's true i'm going with three
concerns
the hong kongese lie we're not gonna
believe it in general
yes speaking in broad generality i know
you may not like it but i don't have a
problem with it so anyone in nevada
uh you let me know if you feel like your
vote counted and what needs to change
there before we move on to pennsylvania
it's actually time to uh
we have uh we have people of course we
check in with our office every now and
then people in the edit bay
uh we check work minute
[Music]
hey even brendan is in there what are
you working on you're editing something
right now i think right
even brendan what no
what i don't that doesn't seem no i
don't understand
okay
i dated three of those
was one a ghost yes
literally two people she looked like the
girl from ring from behind
no types of the same woman oh okay i
don't understand
not a man and a woman see and then just
understand this is this is
going back to the duct tape thing a
little bit does it understand that
showing
the uh south dakota uh uh the south
dakota governor
hurts their case when this when the
governor is better looking than your
host
this beautiful woman right crazy trust
me trust me
right right across the country right now
there are dozens of people with cnn on
airports going well hey wasn't she
why does she do her job put her there
she should have a show and put you in
a gulag yeah cnn's claim she's too
pretty to be smart
why don't you have an extra chromosome
monster like most city
politicians buzz cut lady yeah she
brings back lori
looks like ashley tisdale banged
skrillex and we're supposed to take her
as an authoritative news source it looks
like lena dunham before she found
cake oh they said elena did it before
she found k like
but both those probably because i assume
like that special k increases your
appetite for special k
her finding cake was like christopher
columbus like putting his flag
right yeah and that she was looking for
vegetables but stumbled across cake
no i don't think so at all it was more
like vikings or she was like out of my
way i just mean it changed the world
right yeah also a lot of people were
killed
[Laughter]
stole it from endless previous owners if
cortes
like instead of cortez it was just lena
dunham with a red beard and a funny hat
but she was the same person as today
trying to conquer back then they
wouldn't even have a chip for someone
bitching as much as she does they they'd
have amazon there
it wouldn't even have been an issue
they've been like get out of here
get out of here look at this sure rape
yeah yeah yes it was also verifiable
like
anybody would rape you okay so uh now
let's go on to pennsylvania here
pennsylvania is another one you guys can
feel free to check i want to hit these
facts but you guys can feel free to chat
with opinions other than
polling is that then vote fraud is bad
gerald i don't think i've ever said that
give me something more to go on
i'm sure i didn't say that factual um
you know what let's start with this in
pennsylvania so nevada's done
pennsylvania and michigan i'm really
looking forward to tomorrow but
in pennsylvania um a lot of people will
say well hold on a second actually
that's untrue we had a live stream poll
workers were allowed
in some places they were some places and
we'll get to all that the
misunderstandings thanks ap
uh but watch this video for yourself and
you tell me if it looks like a poll
worker
is actively being turned away no
evidence
you're not letting me in well what no
that's what i tell you
call us police do it if you legally
the city goes very good
i have a city-wide water certificate
it's not for this location
it's not it's just this is the city this
is the city of philadelphia
this is the city of philadelphia it is
i don't know what's more offensive that
our uh democracy is being stolen for us
or
from us or that the poll watcher was
tricked by the old bouncer ah let's go
talk about it outside
close the door you mean there's not a
sex on the beach out here
oh skunked again i like that they
couldn't be bothered to
read the certificate that says good in
all wards
right city good in all wars what can we
do to make sure this doesn't happen well
let's just write on it that it's good in
all wards that'll take care of it
had the same thing happen with a coupon
at tgi fridays
let's talk about this that's because of
the one-way mirrored van that's true
yeah it was a bad idea
and it's not it's not because we can see
the children in the back it's because
you parked in the electric vehicle only
oh
we take the uh we take the global
warming uh seriously feel free to hurt
the kids just not the environment
um so here's the thing poll watchers in
philadelphia to collaborate not only was
going on there
uh they were ordered to stand 20 feet
away until they got a court order
uh which they defied um now the media
fact checked some of these things the 20
feet away as well as that video
this is from usa today here's what's so
interesting like you said
that certificate is good in all wards
right it's city-wide which almost seems
like the poll workers
should know that kind of like i should
know right now
oh the red light that means people can
see what i say
only i'm in charge of the election of
the free world
so here's what the usa today said it was
an honest mistake and when you read it
it even confused me let me read an exact
quote
so you see they're trying to say that it
actually seemed like he was in the wrong
ward and then you realize
oh at the bottom of the paragraph right
before the guy leaves his byline which
is anonymous
um i don't know if it was in this case a
spokesperson for the philadelphia city
commissioner's office stated the act was
quote an honest
mistake kevin feely said during a phone
call with buzzfeed news
that the man had a different war than
was written on his certificate an older
version of the law pertaining to poll
watchers maintains such individuals must
be assigned to specific wards
which is why the poll worker mistakenly
turned the man away turned the man away
see there was a law in the war and if
you're like oh well i guess okay he
shouldn't have been there
and he was mistakenly turned away well i
was like you said it was not different
awards
how was he mistakenly turned away they
never mentioned the new
law and that the guy was officially
credited for
all wards so they said there was an old
law that was kind of confusing and so it
was a mistake want a second
is there a new law is that something
they should have been briefed on because
we heard audio tapes of them briefing
people in detroit and how to board up
polling precincts with bristol boards
just grab a new bristol board it could
be an old project from your
kids kindergarten it don't matter so
long as they can't see [ __ ]
and it's educational well also it's
fraud
and educational like baby einstein
stealing [ __ ]
also do you believe this lady knew that
law no
the one in the welding map yeah exactly
the plastic welding mask
sorry i was working on old information
yeah yeah i'll leave you with your
droplets you can take your drop of [ __ ]
i get non-porous i wanted a mass made of
marble but then i realized i couldn't
see
mm-hmm i tried it
so the lady know that law no there's no
way she knew that law
yeah now if you look into look at this
book it's about right here
paragraph seven sub-section c clearly
states you have to be in the right ward
now if you got a book of new laws you
want to bring it right
we can talk i'm not saying i'm gonna
listen yeah but you can talk all you
want you talk talk talk talk talk talk
ass white [ __ ] love to talk love to
talk talk talk talk talk oh you're
saying i'm breaking the law no
call the police see if i give a [ __ ]
let's be one of them
you can talk to the hand is this still
the 90s do people say that
cause i look at 90 laws i get my laws
from
brandy by the way with i yeah
one from tv show does it matter if it
was an
honest mistake it doesn't matter at this
point the poll watcher was not allowed
in
the the end result is the same whether
you weren't briefed on the new law
whether you knew the law or whether you
just
had a bad day it still happened
the whole point it was missed
no it was not necessarily it bothers me
it's just a guy voting it's the guy
who's got to make sure it's
done properly right right why would you
assume that he's just not allowed inside
right
and by the way honest mistakes don't
usually involve that much shoving
yeah no yeah and call the police go
ahead and call them
detecting a little bit of unhonest yeah
the mistake is like oh i bumped into you
i'm sorry about that doesn't involve
yeah you don't have to lock the doors
and you're like had the pandas
we're seeing it with the body language
expert on these things right right right
body language here you see he's reaching
for a knife but then realizes the camera
so he just commits mild assault by
shoving him
yeah you can see the honesty here yes
here yes
you can clearly see the earnestness in
the face i know that it's difficult
because of the reflection due to the
entirely ineffective mask but uh
as you see the pull she took a sneeze
she took half a sneeze shield from
golden corral that's all it is
it's a sneeze guard that's it sorry
we're gonna say i cut you off
i forgot all right uh now the
coronavirus goes down loading someone
looted my idea so by the way what we're
talking about so you have that then you
have mail-in ballots we talked about how
in uh yesterday what was the state we
did yesterday was it uh
arizona was it was georgia georgia
georgia had an acceptance rate of
mail-in ballots
at 10 times the previous elections now
this is important here in this
kind of trends with the national average
it is about 30 times they were accepted
at a rate of
30 times the mail-in ballots of 2016 in
pennsylvania so
keep in mind uh what that means is in
2016
we didn't just have massive unrequested
mail-in ballots right we had absentee
ballots
i had to vote absentee one time because
on the road doing stand-up and so that's
where you actually have to recruit
at least when i did it you had to
request a ballot you had to verify and
authenticate your address and then you
had to send it in
usually by election yeah that's what
ours was
yeah i didn't i didn't claim reverse
racism sometimes commonly referred to as
racism i just said well yeah it makes
sense there's a date them's the breaks
if i miss the date
right calendars are racist you know
deadlines so that's what i had to do
back then so that was the process back
then
and ballots that were mailed in were
except at accepted at 30 times less so
that means that now
many people who've never voted according
to the voter rolls they've blown
past uh actual voting percentage in
counties from countries where it's
mandated
in some instances and we've seen a
record number of ballots that are empty
except for joe biden at the top of the
ticket but for some reason
all kinds of problems with signatures
we've shown these on air you can see
them yourself it doesn't even it's like
literally it says
i put your john hancock down there one
name says randall
wendell and the other name says john
hancock it's like someone just wrote
john hancock on 30 and put them through
yeah well i like this john fellow like
they were like they were counting money
for the mob
they re-ran the ballots and their
argument back would be that
the process has gotten more secure i
don't know if it's gotten 30 times more
secure
does that mean that the post office has
gotten 30 times better right
in the mail are they making 30 times the
negative profits that they've done for
13 years yeah turns out if you lose
enough money you get really efficient
think about this you have to believe
that right that the post office who have
not turned a profit in 13 years and said
they were not equipped to handle this
election
and were mailing out checks 10 days late
were so efficient
that they were 30 times more effective
in handing in
mail-in ballots also by the same time
people who've never voted before
made sure they got it right from their
den 30 times more effective when people
say well you know there's not enough for
voter fraud again we've already shown
you thousands of votes in a state uh
like georgia where the martial very very
thin thousands of votes we've shown you
that already again without an actual
canvassing without an actual official
recount without an actual official audit
and now
30 times the rate those aren't numbers
to give an example let's say there were
100 thousand ballots mail in ballots
that were sent before right they were
rejected at a rate let's say it was
uh one one percent so what happened is
last election a hundred thousand votes
a thousand got rejected right now this
time 100 000 votes
less than 300 get rejected you add that
up in a state with a few million people
that's not a rounding error that's
winning or losing the state
those are fighting numbers and when you
say you don't want fighting in the
streets
well then don't miscount votes to the
level
that would necessitate fighting in the
streets for some people because they
want their vote to count
5 500 people their votes did not count
in georgia
until this morning because of two flash
drives
you don't think they're not burning
stuff down but i would understand it a
little more than someone burning
something down for
i still don't get it your reason is as
good as mine comment below as to why you
burned down a walgreens
and by the way people were concerned
that those numbers would climb
that the the rate of rejection would
actually go significantly higher in this
election
and they were worried that a bunch of
voters that would be voting for joe
biden wouldn't get counted so
we can go back and play the tapes of
these people saying this and it went
down and they're like oh
yeah oh yeah that's fantastic that's
exactly what we thought would happen and
then of course
breakdown of walgreens because i prefer
cvs i yeah well i do have the better
discounts i don't know why though cvs
still prints out receipts that can
circle the equator four times
like it's comp usa in 2004. i use them
as toilet paper
that's weird you can stuff it in your
jacket for warmth oh wow
50 off buy five get 150 off for pantene
pro v
thanks cvs all i wanted was a 99 arizona
iced tea but you don't restock your cold
beverages
what is the cvs down the road here for
drinks it always looks like you can't
tell if it's a pandemic or just a
tuesday
it's always empty i think it's somebody
who's very lazy there's always a
sandwich in there where you're like who
like who would eat that there's no way
that's not been there for seven years
there's cobwebs on it
if a homeless guy asked me for a dollar
i go i do not have that but i do have 50
1500 worth of paper
it's got war and peace prince what's
this in the back of ballots i don't know
yeah
someone should report that's why it's on
the back i don't need vidal sassoon
product boat tossed uh by the way hit
the notification bell if you are
subscribed on youtube because
subscriptions don't mean a whole lot
there's a little bell right there you
hit it and it'll notify you when new
segments go up and of course we
broadcast monday through thursday
sometimes fridays but monday through
thursday every weekday 10 a.m eastern
going on down the trail with fraud week
pennsylvania
um now here's the thing the trump
campaign that uh the trump campaign they
claimed by the way that there were
different standards for voting in person
um and that voting by mail is
unconstitutional well some people say
well that's just hearsay it's an
argument judges are gonna toss it out
but they don't tell you the argument
well let me give you the argument and
you decide does the argument
hold water depending where your
biological clock is in-person voters
were required to of course we all know
this vote in a controlled environment
you know i'm not lying to you if you've
ever
voted um and of course before election
day
right these were standards they required
matching signatures
because you know like when you signed
when you voted and you like signed yeah
yeah they were just making sure it's
your signature yeah i signed four or
five times as i recall
did you yeah and then they ran it times
10. to get it right that [ __ ] is
exponential
[Laughter]
he also told me what to fill out yes yes
at gunpoint yeah so controlled
environment in a polling station right
at a precinct before election day having
matching signatures
but the 2.65 mail in ballots required
none of that
none of it none of the safeguards
they're not matching again we know that
they're not matching the signatures
because we've seen multiple ballots that
didn't either didn't have any signatures
at all and have been accepted in the
past
or ballots that just don't have
signatures that match which right we
can't do a full auditing so we don't
know how many
but they filled it out from their den so
it could be filled out anywhere
yeah and they could sign anything and uh
by the way uh the pennsylvania court
they decided to legislate
from the bench and say uh oh well
usually it's election day but yeah
give or take three days um i said you
can send it in three days late
is what they said and of course there
was a higher court and this is where i
wish my half asian lawyer was here
saying well no they legislated from the
bench they do not have the authority
to change the voting standard and say
that you have an extra three days
and then a pennsylvania supreme court
said yeah we do and so now uh here's
what's interesting though is um
the ap right they reported so ap this is
considered an authoritative news source
anyone who does news
you always get their newsletters yeah ap
and they were the ones who were really
the source for calling states for a lot
of these places
so the ap claimed that the trump
campaign had dropped
uh the suit which was challenging the
682 000 mail-in ballots i mean
we're talking about mail-in ballots that
were three days late so again whether
you think the the pennsylvania court has
the right to just say we're gonna extend
it three days five days ten days you get
all the days
that's not the argument the point here
is the press reported
that the trump campaign conceded that
argument why because they want you to be
defeated sons of [ __ ] and say well if
the court is tossing it
that must mean that trump doesn't have
an argument well trump's conceding and
he's not even arguing the point anymore
his own lawyers
that must mean that they know they have
nothing you see a lot of that going on
because that's what happened in ap but
here's an actual
quote from the director of
communications uh not stefanopoulos that
was
clinton's guy but now he's a reporter
unbiased
regular cronkite he is not so much but
he needs stilts
so trump's director of communications
responded this story is completely
erroneous our lawsuit in pennsylvania
absolutely still makes an issue of the
682 thousand mail and absentee ballots
that were counted in secret
to write that we have scrapped that
argument requires not
reading the amended complaint again the
issue isn't where we line up and of
course i don't think that the courts
have the right to say
election day plus three i think people
should be held accountable which is why
i have a problem with polling
but the argument here is the people
we're supposed to trust the people who
are put in charge of fact checking where
at facebook at twitter at youtube places
like ap
they falsely reported that the trump
campaign
had rescinded their argument they did
not that combined with people being
shoved by poll workers and welding masks
should terrify
you yeah well this specific argument
that they have is i think one of the
strongest cases and we we talked about
this previously which which state you
thought was going to have movement first
or the strongest case i have always said
pennsylvania has the strongest case
because of this
because the the equal protection
argument that they're making saying that
you didn't treat these voters the same
right is absolutely true and also
allowing people to cure their ballots
after it's been received they they gave
people that authority to do it
curing ballots because the cigar lover
i'm thinking they hang the ballot
no it's not curing like people or
anything else like that yeah
yeah so if you make a mistake on your
feet kiln sorry let me get that
otherwise you'll think that i'm biden
pete
killed the joke is uh in the pile with
yours go ahead yes right so if you make
a mistake on your ballot um you are able
to fix that mistake you're able to cure
right that right if if it's something
minor right so there's a couple of
things the naked ballot
vaccine for your ballot exactly if you
if you had a naked ballot that did not
have that outer envelope the secrecy
envelope which it is supposed to have
uh the signature isn't necessarily
matching or some other minor mistakes on
this
and the signature matching is not a
minor mistake by the way if somebody
forges it incorrectly
throw it out it's an honest mistake not
again
don't look at me that way damn you
my ballot came with saran wrap
i don't even know what that means clear
but i'll laugh
it they can't let them do that
all right i want to hear his explanation
because this is where uh right right so
you're not supposed to be able to do
that and so instead of
just arguing that those ballots
shouldn't have been the 2.65 million
mail-in ballots there shouldn't have
been about 700 000 allowed after the
deadline they're saying
even if you agree with the court in
pennsylvania
they treated these ballots differently
than everybody else's and that is
breaking the law
and by the way hey cnn right now they're
saying trump fires official who disputed
his baseless election
claims this is not what's happened by
the way they've also said oh some of
these suits were dropped in certain
states here's what's happened again
the media doesn't tell you the why the
context and sometimes they just lie as
they lied about
oh well the trump campaign they've
rescinded their complaint here no they
did not
in this case well not necessarily in
this case i don't know this exact case
but uh there have been several lawyers
who have been fired from certain states
and then moved or sometimes ago we have
to allocate certain resources because we
have a more effective argument
in another state there are many many
many lawsuits right now
some of which are designed to fight at a
state level and some of which are
designed to be kicked up to the supreme
court so the fact that lawyers
are either recusing themselves or
they're being
let go because they want to allocate
resources to other states does not mean
that they're just conceding this
territory that's important again
this is to try and make you think that
the battle is over here's the thing
maybe joe biden won absolutely i i'm
fine accepting that
but no one should be okay with this
level of fraud
or potential fraud and irregularities at
this point for me it's enough when you
find when you find 5 000 votes
several weeks after in one in one state
one county
for me when six thousand votes got okay
you know what that's enough
if i'm saying no election fraud there
are only maybe one
or two or maybe a hundred if you're
lucky that you'll find a recount and
someone goes oh
six thousand you got me that's one for
you
that's what i would be saying just like
if we recounted this we found out that
joe biden by some act
of satan got 10 million
more votes than barack obama no no okay
fine i'll concede but you said they were
no front and i just found
i just look oh i just found another one
there's another 5 000 votes
yeah exactly but if you're finding 6 000
that means there's a lot more
in my opinion yes i mean i know there's
no fact but that's ridiculous especially
if you feel
like one county right so yeah especially
if you're doing like enough to look
around
the lightest possible version of an
audit this isn't
this is a recount like you're not even
trying to find additional votes you're
trying to make sure you count the ones
you have correctly and by the way it's
taking the fifth pocket of your jeans
and you're like
whoops yeah how do you have cargo pants
that's my small pocket where i usually
keep my baggie between counting ballots
but it turns out
i put ballots in the baggie pocket
that's not called a baggy pocket well
that's how i refer to it
in the background along with the let's
talk about it outside click
it oh mr jimmy ballot in the ballot in
the
baggy pockets i should have known better
than to trust ballot in the baggy pocket
jim
he always pulls one over me yeah we'd
like you to run this place like studio
54.
that's how it needs to go
share and share a like mr baggy in uh
pocket um
by the way all of these sources are
available at lidar with credit.com
that's one thing we're changing because
i know some people out there are lazy
and and i do mean lazy because you can
see the source on the screen
but a lot of people look i don't wanna i
don't wanna have to type it in so could
you just make it so i just click and i'm
sure some people will be like well can
you not make it so i can i click
on the youtube we can't do that because
we don't run youtube but if you're going
to come click the description you'll see
all of these sources
they're publicly available and hey if
you think i'm wrong go ahead and comment
uh more information on pennsylvania
according to the polling data there are
people over 120 years old who voted i'm
sure they're all good
mix-ups people requested received and
returned mail-in ballots all on the same
day and there were other ballots that
were returned before they were requested
huh wow that's one hell of a return
policy harold postal service is awesome
can you imagine if someone from kohl's
just showed up at
your door like here's your ninja blender
you're like i didn't buy one returned it
out of my hands bye i'm terribly
confused or if they're like you will
tomorrow
by the way i'm pretty sure that i
single-handedly and responsible for bed
bath and beyond changing their uh return
policy
expensively no what did you do did they
turn things like three years later
because it was never it was like just
open-ended and my logic
is you know you used to buy a vacuum you
used to buy a blender and it lasted and
i don't mean we'd turn it three years
later we might return it like a year and
a half later
and you expect it to last like old
appliances but you get it it breaks in
eight months and so we would return it
and
sometimes you're just like you have a
receipt no oh go get whatever you want
like thank you bed bath
and now like no more
it's because of covet they started the
problems i hate to say i think everybody
does that
but that's not good that's how kohl's
was too oh yeah they were
okay you just turn anything you want oh
anything at all you could just go to
like
yard sales yeah yeah
i bet you they the kohl's workers or the
people they put at the polling precinct
they mark everything up it's like oh you
would like a pair of slippers well that
is six hundred dollars but what's the
seventy percent off in the 10's enough
it's a four yeah you said you said
you've worked poles before no i worked
in
kohl's i worked at kohl's and that jc
penny my father tried to get in
i shoved him out and then i flipped out
my welding mask job
well done i've earned myself a baggie
get your own baggie so are these all
clerical heirs 120 year old vote
people voting people having the ballot
sent to them voting sending it back same
day ballots being returned before they
were ever requested where in some other
counties they just keep in mind again is
it applied equally
i think they're still counting arizona
well this is going to take a long time
you got that man's ballot in
before the day that he even requested it
because that wasn't a day
i just think that's efficient it really
doesn't mean it's we knew how you were
going to vote before you did so we just
took care of it
we're supposed to believe that philly's
efficient you can't even fix your bell
how long does that take come on get some
day raiders history my ass
[Laughter]
so now we have nevada we have
pennsylvania we've gone through georgia
and we didn't know what else we have we
still have wisconsin and we still have
uh i don't know if we did arizona but
tomorrow is michigan because michigan
has some very interesting data not only
just recently that we just
showed you four about a ballot counted
four times and people being doxxed
but uh michigan is interesting because
of some counties that change yeah
um it doesn't tell the full story when
you understand that donald trump was
getting more of the minority vote more
than a women vote than anyone before and
joe biden was underperforming with all
those votes but all of a sudden 149 000
came in in wayne county
and only 6 000 were for donald trump
again in the dead unbelievable remember
there was the typo of 128 000 i think in
wisconsin
they're like oh it was a typo well this
actually happened 149 000 in michigan
only 6 000 for donald trump in wayne
county so he over performed with all
these demographics which we were told he
ever
everyone thought he was racist blacks
hated him women hated him and then he
only
underperformed and biden only over
performed in major metropolitan areas
where we
saw these shenanigans going on at the
polls it does not make sense and you
also see in very
staunchly republican counties in
michigan that the margins were a lot
slimmer
yeah it's bizarre and atypical
in every which way and the issue right
now is
the left is always they're the party who
always wanted investigation think about
this yeah they wanted they did four
years of investigating russia they
claimed let's look at their claims they
claimed that donald trump worked with
putin they claimed
donald trump with cambridge analytica
they came uh they claimed that donald
trump was watching russian pissing
prostitutes at the kremlin right
all of these claims they claimed that uh
that he was funneling money from his
all of these claims and they were
running investigations that were a sham
that led to nothing it took an aeg to
step in and say
all right let's put a stop to this but
now all of a sudden they're the party of
we don't need to investigate we don't
have time nothing
nothing no questions at all what if
donald trump had bought
i don't know 5600 votes by just paying
someone to remove the memory cards
i don't think there'd be a fire probably
wouldn't
but hey you know instead of instead of
actually doing an investigation they're
rushing to certify
the election results not just trying to
do it by december 14th which i think is
when most people are supposed to be
doing it by
rushing to certify it and doxxing people
who get in their way
although twitter was going to fact check
donald trump if he claimed victory uh in
march
really yeah jack well i'm just exactly
but jack joyce said any claims that
donald trump has won
two fact checks what are you doing jack
dorsey
ayahuasca so did he even win wayne
county then
donald trump yeah no no no he didn't win
it no he didn't win wayne county that's
my confusion of what they found
yesterday sorry that's what i
no no they found all a bunch of
irregularities like yes being counted
four times no but donald trump didn't
win wayne county
okay which doesn't surprise me because
of detroit but now they're trying to say
of course if wayne county if it's not
certified which is why they start
doxxing people yeah cause i knew he lost
it but i didn't know if they found
enough to where he would win
well they found enough irregularities
where they wanted to halt it to run an
investigation exactly then all of a
sudden they started
doxxing two of the four certifiers yeah
and they said all right you know what
listen uh
uh apparently these people don't
understand that your internet lasts
forever so you know you've already been
doxxed
you're in it now you're screwed just i
hate to say it
move and keep your address unlisted
there are ways to do that
but you're in it they're not gonna let
up yeah they've sent the torch mob after
you do the right thing you know there
are irregularities we know there are
irregularities there have been total
local elections tossed out six figure
votes
due to irregularities do the right thing
they're not going to stop
doxxing you just like antifa and black
lives matter are not going to stop
harassing people regardless of a biden
sign on their yard
appeasing the mob is futile this is
going to get absolutely nuts
regardless of how much the election is
contested people need to understand that
black lives matter was created under
barack obama under the first black
president in the history of the united
states
people started protesting because they
believed that racism was worse than ever
one you might as well be honest because
you're going to have two groups at you
so you might as well side with at least
one of them i mean that's the reality
people are gonna come at you
side with the people with guns exactly
although mine i don't know i think it
might be your uh kid there
gary yeah well i feel right around with
guns it also gets a little bit worse
because the state said that they would
just go ahead and certify the vote if
wayne kenny didn't they're like fine
we'll take care of it
and i i thought the counties had the
right to do that first and that you guys
were supposed to certify what they said
well i also thought poll workers had the
right to watch for accounting oh no no
no but instead they're being shoved out
with blow torch masks yeah
you're lucky i don't go in and get my
actual blow torch i just have my mask
don't make me mad don't make me get my
[ __ ] glasses
[Laughter]
all right so any other commentary so
that's we're continuing uh fraud week
we're continuing it tomorrow with
michigan i don't know if we're doing
wisconsin there are so many
irregularities but right
michigan is the one to me where uh
opinion
i certainly don't think dividend one
michigan and again i just think we need
an investigation i will accept joe biden
as my legitimate president
if there is an investigation into these
verifiably documented irregularities but
right now let's move on to something
else operation warp speed and the
vaccines because people now are talking
about the vaccines
i wonder why don't you love cnn by the
way baseless election fraud claims every
single one of them
hold on a second 6 000 votes switched 5
000 votes found what they're doing is
they're trying to hang on the word fraud
saying
we don't know if there's fraud and by
the way the case where there was fraud
yesterday they forced the director of
the election to
step down from a job that doesn't exist
anymore even though it was a volunteer
so technically it's not fraud it's like
oh it's just an irregularity of
thousands of votes right oh tomato
here's the thing they're doing as well
it's just like the racist claim it's
just like saying everybody who agrees
with donald trump is a racist and the
average american is like well i don't
want to be a racist okay well i've got
to look into this and everybody who says
well
why this sounds really weird they found
votes wait a minute they're baseless
claims
i don't want to be a [ __ ] or some
conspiracy theorist so i'll just let it
go
yeah that's exactly what they're doing
right now to the general public watching
that
right well a lot of people that voted
even said look what i don't want to go
in there i just want all the
the riots to stop i want i want to stop
being scared i don't think that
i don't think that's fair that you
should be able to vote based on fear
right in that regard
yeah no you absolutely shouldn't have to
vote asymptote which is funny because
they were trying to talk about in cnn oh
you look at donald trump doom and gloom
and a positive message from joe biden
nobody said that america was dead unless
you voted for him yeah
that's right america is dead with the
lowest unemployment ever
we've entirely wiped out the economic
losses from the pandemic
outside of little businesses but
democrats you don't care about that a
lot of those people won't get their
businesses back but you hate them anyway
you want to talk some out of existence
and we're down to a 6.9
unemployment rate which barack obama
would have hit his
knees yeah and thanking the spirits if
he hit an unemployment rate of six point
nine percent in the first two years of
his presidency
in his knees jacob marley
so let's get to the vaccines because
everyone now is talking about the
vaccines
okay pfizer uh right they had their
vaccine this was just announced this
morning it was 90 effective
now it's 95 effective and that's because
there's uh
another vaccine from moderna that's 94.5
percent effective
it almost seems like they're making it
up yeah that's like a price is what was
there
a little bit more yes pfizer came out so
90
and then madonna said oh yeah i won this
94.5 and then i heard 94.5
95. they said okay 94.5 and one dollar
still not better than the human body
which is at 99.00 yeah
but it's still let me make sure i check
my sources three times better than the
average postal service delivery rate
except on elections 124 percent
you're working that extra i'm just
getting i've got to be sure to get the
vaccine that's 95
effective against a 99 survival rate
right yes i got to make sure i
gotta go get that vaccine i think the
death rate from the vaccine will likely
be higher than the death rate
there's someone in there panicking like
gene wilder and see no evil when they're
like oh listen all we have here is the
moderna one wait is that the 94.5
no no are you out of the chain no i need
the fizer
the fight is up think about it you're
gonna go with 99.99
efficacy rate and now you have a choice
for its vaccine that's 94.5 or 95
effective here's the issue remember when
donald trump they
said it was absolutely impossible
because verbatim donald trump said
we might actually have a vaccine uh
ready come november no in case you've
forgotten
here he is we're looking to get it by
the end of the year if we can
maybe before we're doing tremendously
well
now to fact check the president's
remarks nbcnews.com political reporter
jane tim
joins me now
how realistic is this goal michael
jackson's ghost
you know i talked with some of the best
vaccine creators
out there some of the people who created
things like the rubella vaccine that all
of us have
have gotten to go to school and they
said 12 to 18 months
is optimistic it depends on the science
but it's doable in this
all hands on deck environment i didn't
hear anybody say by the end of the year
was likely or probable as the president
said i'm pretty confident she wouldn't
know the difference between a rubella
vaccine or
rhubarb she spoke with someone see that
yeah yeah i spoke with somebody i spoke
with someone who says that's uh
very unlikely that we have a vaccine the
scientists who follow the science
is this this science or is this just
science i want to be clear is it the
science
capital s like the noun like your god or
is this science
where we have a 95 and a 94.5
effective vaccine that's true you said
none
you said none donald trump said maybe
one you said no now there's two
[ __ ] off and she was she was so smug
about it at the end
yeah people want america to fail they
don't want us to have a vaccine no they
don't want us to have trust in our
elections go ahead
and their fact check is this hasn't
happened before right like we're saying
what's happening
it's happening right now that's the
whole point it depends on the sciences
i'm pretty sure we haven't had a reality
tv show host before who awarded arsenio
hall it's news news we're a little
we're in uncharted territory here you
guys said it was unprecedented times
yeah by the way with the vaccine
announcement the dow closed at a record
high erasing the
boom all the last of the pandemic losses
we don't have to wait eight years for
that
to to come back well we know we're gonna
have to wait if if joe biden is
certified we have to wait another four
years oh okay
[Laughter]
just shows up on barbara walters and
he's a show a little man with tennis
elbows
yeah i want to see it like a apprentice
scene with all of the head of the like
the vaccine corporations where he's like
firing all those things i do not believe
that donald trump is racist at all but i
do believe that awarding arsenio hall
and celebrity apprentice was
see look i gave it to a black guy who
really sucks
the worst black guy he put a cape on mel
farr
if you can find that picture this is the
least entertaining black bear
anyone the greatest thing you'll ever
see is him
caping mail far
mel farr was a detroit lion and he was
actually
the uh most successful black businessman
in the 80s and
uh donald trump gave him him an award
right that's cool and he used to fly
around on his commercials and
see people like tito jackson who were
like can i get a deal and he's like yeah
jackson that's not as good as michael
and you would have sinbad on the
commercials it was great
good times and he would have really low
interest rates like 43 percent oh
that ruined sinbad's comedy because
riding around on trump's private jet was
no longer relatable like
you know how people all be in the jet
and can't use a bathroom because they
stink it up it's like people like
my what and it's like you are not good
[Music]
i was just saying i love norm's bit
about sinbad how he lost to him on uh
our search where he's just like you ever
go to side you've got a sock store and
you can't find somebody to catch you out
and all you want to do is buy socks
and he's like the whole place is crying
laughing and he's like i don't think
that's ever happened
that's cause you don't shop at cvs
rather than giving you a socks they
putting under a seat you like what's
going on
i'm trying to buy socks and they punch
you in the face
they punch you in the face with a
blowtorch mask you're like i'm just
trying to vote
you know what i mean you can't touch
this one
um all right so erase the losses of the
dao and uh here's the thing a lot of
people understand
it's true the left those in the media
they couldn't see that this would be
possible whereas conservatives did
believe would be possible because people
have talked about warp speed right and
you see these things a lot like people
have used the term star wars missile
defense system that's actually a term
that was coined by the media that's not
the term that ronald reagan used but
then people believe
uh they have a grasp as to what it is
you hear the term warp speed and people
just think well this is unrealistic
donald trump's not a politician he
doesn't know
warp speed was basically this it was uh
cutting regulation right deregulating
and cutting red tape so we would allow
a pharmaceutical companies we would
partner with private industry to allow
them to get a vaccine to market
more quickly allowed certain processes
that would have to take place
sequentially to happen at the same time
in other words okay you have to get this
approval then you have to wait it sits
on a desk for four months while the
secretary doesn't read it then you have
to wait another nine months so that's
why cnn was saying
12 to 16 months maybe but by november
they didn't read what warp speed was
they didn't read the plan just like they
didn't read the five
page green new deal so this is important
to know the reason you have two vaccines
is because of all the things that people
claim they hate deregulation you know
the disney film that shows up
here's a contrast so this is why i ask
does anyone out there really believe
that biden would have brought it to
market faster considering that operation
warp speed
was nothing but a package of things
biden hates he has a long-standing
history of course
of opposing all of these actions and
he's already pledging to enact more
regulation as soon as he takes office
um and this is something too with
operation warp speed they actually
pledged ahead of time to purchase doses
huge right giving companies an incentive
to get and here's something too it was
about having companies compete
this is a big part of operation war
speed we're going to cut red tape we're
going to deregulate and listen
we understand that maybe it might come
with more side effects we'll have to
create more transparency so people know
some people who may have covet or on a
ventilator they might take slight
stomach upset
if offered this vaccine and this was the
purpose of it so businesses started
competing against each other
and now you see i think it's pfizer
saying that we'll make some doses
available right away
yeah competition business this is also
why we're not a nonprofit here at uh
ladder with crowder this is why we have
mudclub lot of credit.com club a
business
can actually do more good than a
non-profit because it can create it can
bake more pies
it can continually grow and do good
on an ongoing basis as opposed to well
the well runs dry
that's what happened with operation war
speed this is the opposite again going
back to biden to contrast it
he had his thing was a cancer it was
moonshot the program all these
warp speed moonshot he wanted to name it
goldeneye but copyright
right he just wanted to paint a bunch of
six-year-olds gold like you can't do
that and smell that i saw it on the
cover of gq that's a bot it's a swimsuit
issue and i get it they trick you with
body paint it's
yeah those models are elusive you can't
do it because she's eight
there's like died what someone died
no the blonde one oh oh the gold oh the
gold i thought something happened on cnn
because you were looking at the scene
oh no no i was like poppy harlow come on
that's the one
quality fingers crossed so fingers
crossed
fingers crossed that she makes it yes
that's what i meant
long life this isn't the kumiya show
here i'm sorry
big old target i'm of course kidding to
people with the to people who don't
understand that he's a comedian yeah i'm
not sure immediate well
i don't know let's just ban it as racist
um so cancer it was a moonshot program
he thought it was bad that companies go
go and research us we have at the
website littlecredit.com he thought it
was bad for companies to be competing on
similar projects and so
he wanted them and he wanted to force
them to share info and work together
here's the thing it's great in theory to
force people to share
anyone who's ever tried to force
children to share
you don't get good results let alone
competing businesses in the same
industry if you just force mcdonald's
and burger king to share
yeah it would be burgernolts
mick whopper mcquaffer that'd be racist
i like burgers and as a matter of fact
actually this is something i i forgot
about this
uh there were some provisions in the
moonshot program that actually removed
competition it was so severe
that uh drug prices started to
absolutely soar even washington post
labeled the product of failure and you
know they really didn't want to label
the project an absolute failure
uh and before by the way before i go to
jail's point if you guys are watching
right now 100 something thousand people
hundred fifty thousand however many of
you are watching here and on blaze
uh this can help just hit like right now
those of you watching hey you watching
right now
hit the like button uh and afterwards
you can leave a comment as soon as it's
archived just uh just write uh
write uh write uh maga never say die or
we'll also accept penis that will uh
help us greatly in the youtube algorithm
and then we should be in suggested feed
but we probably won't just hit like i'm
not sure about the penis thing i don't
think
i'm not allowed i feel good about it um
so basically you just get out of the way
and let the private sector do what it
does right joe biden displays that he
has no understanding of how companies
operate who are in competition with one
another every day of the week
right they are going out there trying to
beat the other guy and that's the
motivation that they need and also if
they have financial incentive to get
there first
and they have to they have to abide by
the trial rules they they can't cut
corners on some of this stuff because
there's too much oversight
they will go out and do a fantastic job
that's what they know how to do working
together
that's like saying macy's and gimbal
should have probably just had the same
sale right and work together that one
does men's one does women's it doesn't
work out and so he shows he has no idea
and two
he is the guy coming in with more
regulation he is the guy coming back
raising taxes and saying we need the
government to shut down the economy
right now do you think there is any way
in the world
that he would ever come in and say you
know what this is fine you got plenty of
time to do the trials oh wait we don't
have to ask that question we can go back
to the tape
earlier in the year and say it wasn't
going to be safe to come out with a
vaccine because the trials would be
rushed and they couldn't possibly do it
think about when they say they talk
about the science and the science has
become a religion i believe in following
science hey science says it's 95
effective from pfizer 94.5 from modern
sorry madonna
no no 95.5 now they just came out with
them did they really do five points
i don't know i wouldn't die yeah they're
just gonna tweak some numbers just hire
some poll workers from wayne county
just kill a few of the people that you
know the study um you have to look at
they go we deny the science
okay donald trump band travel from the
hub right kind of like atlanta as a hub
for delta
well uh wuhan is the hub for shitty
viruses
and donald trump banned travel from
there you had joe biden say that's uh
ethnocentric that's xenophobic
now we look at the science everything
that led to us getting a vaccine
right now in november though they're
acting like joe biden is already
president because they're trying right
yeah credit
facebook even removed donald trump's uh
c i don't know if they put it back his
label is president he's still president
guys
joe biden wanted to do the exact and if
president will do the exact
opposite it's been clear you can look at
his policies you've only got
48 years of it yeah and donald trump
every step of the way he was fought they
said he didn't
he didn't follow the science that there
was no way we could get this in november
there was no way we could get it before
the end of the year so joe biden's
solution in following the science
was put on a mask made from your dish
towel donald trump lycomer hate him got
it done from
other companies didn't even seize
control of a private sector because he's
not a stalinist and now you have
two vaccines before you sit down for
turkey and stuffing
how about you know what please and thank
you is what i want to hear from you jim
prosciutto and stelter
and then sit down right i got a question
for you october 21st this announcement
is made
donald trump wins handily do you agree
like if they announced this on october
21st instead of announcing it the week
after oh
yeah like if this stuff comes out before
kind of like the unemployment falling
right exactly yeah no i think it would
have made a huge difference but
incredible you know what
ah them's the brakes it's just the
united states of america
it's just the one nation in the history
of the world who left the most powerful
nation that ever existed the english
empire british empire to become
the most powerful nation the next
century that's never happened before or
since
and for some reason people [ __ ] about
us being the world police but we go into
countries liberate them and ask for
nothing more than the land in which to
bury the dead who provided them with
that right
and canada is still allowed to exist as
a country it's
just the future teetering in the balance
of that guy the united states of america
and you want to hand it over to the
person who for 48 years did
nothing except support segregation
oppose bussing and read the right act to
clarence thomas all right
good luck america but that's why i'm not
conceding defeat i will fight tooth and
nail absolutely
until we have the results okay listen
people right now hit like if you're
watching that really helps this video
we are going to go for another half hour
on you off of youtube
on mug club with some topics that cannot
be discussed on youtube we're also going
to play a make us laugh game take your
chat
um and uh please don't upload things
that we talk about a mug club to youtube
because we don't violate youtube's
policies here but you can bet that we do
exclusively on modclub uh youtube
sorry